the financial world is constantly
changing with the advancing
digitalization in the 21st century this
process has accelerated rapidly opening
up new opportunities to think about
Finance differently digital currencies
such as Bitcoin and co- shake the world
positively and
negatively the concept of tokenization
opens a new chapter in the history of
capital investment
decentralized Democratic controllable
non-stop these are the promises of
tokenization but what are tokens anyway
and how do they work mcconomy takes a
look at the complex world of tokens
examines Theory versus practice and
talks to experts from the crypto
andantex
[Music]
scine as early as about 5,000 years ago
people traded by exchanging goods or
services over time opportunities
developed to also trade shares in goods
or services and even sell them to the
public in order to raise
Capital this is how the stock markets
came into being where companies offer
individual small company shares to a
variety of investors to invest in the
future of the
company this need for shareholding has
increased more and more and ultimately
developed into the Global Financial
Market tokenization meets this need in
an even more extreme
way this is because tokenization is a
further segmentation of a unit or
component into other individual
components a kind of
fractionalization for example shares can
also be further fractioned and the
resulting units can inter turn be
traded however the special and new thing
about tokenization is not the
segmentation but it's linking with
another process that makes tokenization
interesting in the first place the
digital and decentralized storage of the
fractions on a
blockchain individual sectors of the
market for tokenized assets are
currently still in a kind of Discovery
or experimentation
phase its value is estimated at less
than $20
billion the value of the total market
for digital assets is about 350 billion
us this is where the enormous growth
potential becomes
clear tokenization and blockchain
Technology could fundamentally change
the financial and banking
sector by 2027 this growth will increase
dramatically to an estimated $6.89
billion
ftech is one of the biggest players that
will shake up the digital token game in
2022 the United States held the largest
market share but what is tokenization
how do all these new token-based players
operate in the fintech market what is
their agenda and what are their
products in Europe Luxembourg based
tokeny Solutions is one of the market
leaders in providing an Institutional
and modular endtoend platform that
enables the issuance transfer and
management of tradable digital assets
and security
tokens such as tokenized loans
structured debt Securities stocks and
funds this private B2B company provides
an endtoend platform for the unified
issuance management and trading of
service and security
tokens the company valuation for to
tokeny Solutions ranges from 22 to $33
million with a revenue estimate of $6.5
million for the year and a fund of $1
million the company uses ethereum and
polygon's blockchain technology and
works with the RC 3643 token
standard another interesting player in
the European market is the Berlin based
company bit
Bond they have launched the first
security token offering in Europe This
was approved by the German Financial
regulator Baffin in
2019 bitbond is a technology provider
for the tokenization infrastructure of
digital assets their web fre product
token tool allows their customers to
create manage and distribute tokens and
nfds through evm
chains the bit Bond token or bb1 is a a
security Bond token that can be
purchased with Bitcoin ethereum Stellar
or Euro the value per token is equal to
one
euro their global market share is
currently less than
0.1% but with a team size of less than
50 people it is valued at around 16 to19
million us as a
company bitbond is a private company
with a capital of $13.2 million its
revenues will be around $2 million Us in
2023 but how does it work
exactly bitbond uses the erc20 token
standard this is the most commonly used
security token in the fintech
industry he stands for tokenized assets
that comply with current regulations for
Securities in the form of a
token and through a company such as
bitbond or tokeny Solutions the buyer
can buy and trade such a security as a
token the acquired token is implemented
on a blockchain these blockchains are
called ethereum or
polygon I'm Ros laav bre founder and CEO
of bitbond a token is a term that has
been around for a long time and it
basically stands for the fact that an
object or digital good stands for
something else for example if you go to
a funfare and pay admission you often
get a token a plastic chip which you
then hand in in the carousel for example
and that's where the term originally
comes from my name is Marcus kuga I am a
co-founder of token
Forge the best known standard is the
rc20 token
standard it's basically just a small
register in which anyone who has
received a token there is granted access
and is the only one who can move it with
a private
key this is what is meant by
tokenization in the blockchain and
that's what happens without regulations
and without excess from any
administrator or from any regulated
party with a high risk that if you lose
your private key you won't be able to
access that token and you won't be able
to move it you won't be able to sell
it from a technical point of view a
token is basically a database entry and
it says which address which is basically
the digital place where a token is
stored how many pieces how many tokens
has and this is implemented by what is
called program code which in the context
of blockchains is also called smart
contracts blockchains of smart
contracts but basically it is program
code that describes what the technical
properties of the token are and who owns
the token and who holds these
tokens it is crucial for tokenization
which involves creating database entries
connected to specific token owner rights
to have a register or database where the
entries can be easily read and securely
stored lc20 standard fulfills this
function and is implemented on a
blockchain ensuring
security token represents a value or
service they have been present since
approximately 2014 or 2015 when ethereum
blockchain was developed the first
blockchain where digital assets such as
tokens could be
created this initiated the development
of digital tokens and since then the
term has been in use within Financial
technology now with blockchain
technology using cryptography and
signatures individuals can take more
personal
responsibility this is because all
participants can verify the OWN
ownership and transfer of
assets the private key public paay
ensures the secure transfer of these
assets cryptocurrencies are also tokens
created and managed by companies or
other entities rather than institutions
technically cryptocurrencies are not
currencies but function as digital
assets that allow for exchange and trade
these digital assets are generated
through initial coin offerings I
CEOs initial coin offering the inaugural
initial coin offering was of ethereum's
creation introducing the technical token
concept for commercial
use subsequently many other companies
leverage these technical capabilities
and ued additional
tokens my name is irn valer I am the
head of policy for the European
blockchain
Association if you want to buy the
argument that crypto is political I
think it is um and I think it's been
political since the Genesis block so if
you if you look at actually what's
inscribed in the Genesis block so the
first block of the Bitcoin blockchain
it's Chancellor on the brink second
bailout to Banks right and this was
during the the height of the 2008
financial crisis and uh specifically you
know you can look at the Genesis block
as a picket sign it was it was a protest
really against um what many people
viewed as Financial injustices that were
that were incurred um at the cost of the
people for the benefit at the cost of
the majority for the benefit of a
minority tokenization and
cryptocurrencies are shaping a new
section of the capital investment
history this Innovative investment
method is transforming Society politics
and
markets the Innovative concept allows
the division of assets into numerous
small fractions although not A New
Concept fractional ownership is
consistently popular in fin financial
instruments companies have historically
been divided into smaller fractions
through shares or funds yet the novel
aspect is registering these fractions as
digital tokens on a
blockchain from a technical perspective
there are three primary standards that
dominate the industry although numerous
others exist these three can effectively
map all use cases companies utilizing
this technology produce tokens of which
there are thousands while there are
approximately 5 million distinct tokens
presently in circulation they are all
based on the same technical standards
however various values can be
represented using them for instance
stable coins are a type of digital
currency that represent Fiat currencies
like the Euro and the dollar
additionally tokens Can represent
Securities including bonds or shares
tokenization allows you to train
transfer value with a technical
substrate that enables the removal of a
lot of different frictions and these
frictions also lead to cost reductions
so instantaneous settlement
fractionalization it opens up the door
for new use cases like paper use models
streaming money and generally uh the
ability to take real world assets and
represent them in a digitalized form and
then offer them to investors in new ways
to package Financial products um the
ability to ease frictions in crossb
payments as well from an Institutional
perspective and I think also what's very
important is tokenization um
tokenization within blockchain has the
ability to uh produce a higher level of
financial agency and financial inclusion
um which I think is ultimately really
important otherwise why are we doing all
of
this all assets can be digitized and
standardized enhancing liquidity and
transparency automation of processes is
now possible to an unprecedented
extent software developers have been
considering ways to standardize tokens
the importance of doing so lies in the
fact that tokens are held in digital
wallets and not every wallet can store
every type of
token therefore it has been suggested
that a standard should be established to
enable wallets to support as many types
of tokens as possible developers propos
open-source software and the market
adopted particular technical standards
based on their
effectiveness these standards have
become prevalent with two dominant token
variants the erc20 standard for fungible
tokens and the erc721 standard for
non-fungible tokens these ideas
initially suggested by developers have
since become indispensable and are
widely used throughout the
world but the true highlight of
tokenization lies in the affordable
entry prices for investors that are
associated with the smaller Stakes the
one challenge that uh that blockchain
crypto or are I should say the crypto
faces um and you see this in
decentralized finance is the is the end
user or the you know the user experience
right using these Financial products and
services is often times tricky and
challenging or requires a certain level
of technical literacy that not everyone
has and also at the end of the day um
it's generally driven by interest I
don't think you know you can make the
argument and say that everyone will use
this all the time everywhere uh because
that isn't the case with anything now so
why why would it be any different you
know human nature is a Fickle thing so I
think that the point should be to make
it as easy to use as possible as
frictionless as seamless as
possible issures can save money through
tokenization which enables them to
access funds directly without the need
for an intermediary th eliminating the
high fees associated with working with
investment Banks or other
institutions I'm elizabeta palnik I'm an
economist background and to this day I
help basically crypto asset service
providers Law Firm consulting firm
navigate through this new European
regulatory regime that we have in crypto
asset which we all ma Market in crypto
asset the MAA is an EU legal framework
for cryptocurrencies and tokens that are
traded on digital platforms it replaces
the individual regulations of the
individual countries the MAA basically
aim to Target some specific Assets in
the crypto in the crypto industry and
certain Services linked to those crypto
assets so if we take the paral
parallelism to the the traditional
financial sector we have miid which
cover financial instruments now we have
MAA that covers uh some type of crypto
assets which are in three big categories
uh which are the stable coins uh and um
the other crypto assets including uh
utility
token with the implementation of the
markets in crypto assets regulation
called MAA a consistent eu-wide
framework has been established so it
will change a lot of things in the in
the regulatory landscape uh and also in
the crypto industry itself because as we
know all the continent have their own
approach or sometimes they don't have
any Approach at all so I think it will
change a lot of things and also within
the financial sector as well uh why
because the traditional financial sector
so far if you go to a bank and you want
to buy some Bitcoin your Banker will
most likely refuse this request some of
them they they jump and Bard it but 99%
will say no we don't do it after M comes
into Force right now what they can do is
actually they can offer those services
without even having the MAA license
which can be quite a bit of poic because
it's not because your bank or financial
institutions that you can actually
understand and you have the experience
and the knowledge to provide those
services cryptocurrencies are traded via
crypto exchanges utility tokens
represent a specific benefit or
functionality on a platform there are
different types of tokens that can serve
as financial instruments security tokens
act as digital Securities they can have
the characteristics of shares or
bonds and security token
is a security token usually certifies a
security it is technically referred to
as the rc20 token and is similar to a
fungible token with some additional
features it is crucial to identify the
token holders for Securities and
specific technical settings can be
implemented to restrict the transaction
action of these tokens to a particular
white list of recipients by approving
which recipients can hold the token you
are indicating their
authorization security tokens are
commonly designed this way as assurers
usually need to know and sometimes may
be legally mandated to know the owner of
the
tokens utility tokens on the other hand
refer to tokens that operators platforms
or specific Curren
imagine that for instance you do not
utilize standard currency on social
media but a token that has been
developed particularly for these
platforms subsequently you can exchange
this token for certain features on the
platform the process of tokenization
starts with Gathering objective
information about the asset this may
involve obtaining a detailed depiction
of a property or an inventory of
artworks within a collection along with
their specific specific
attributes the collected data is then
digitized and securely stored a unique
token is subsequently created that
represents the ownership rights to the
physical asset being described the
digital token is securely stored on the
blockchain and owing to this specific
information Bears a distinct digital
signature of the
asset there is considerable opposition
because it represents a new technology
and a paradigm shiting
approach previously when moving a
security from made B physical transfer
was necessary hence the creation of
Securities now however there is only a
register it is sufficient to modify
exess rates to a token and transfer
it in essence the security is now linked
to the asset and no longer freely
transferable security this change has
various consequences for the processes
involved our current objective is to
integrate all the available Technologies
such as digital identities digital
currencies and tokenization in a manner
that achieves genuine democratized
access once a token has been created and
saved on a blockchain it can be managed
through smart contracts smart contracts
allow for rent payments to be
transferred to an investor in proportion
to their investment as soon as the rent
is received alternatively a smart
contract can automatically trigger
payments once specific project
Milestones are reached the interesting
thing about token is you could say it's
a smart contract that is registered on a
blockchain but in the end we talk about
programmable values I don't want to say
money here because there might be a
difference between money and its
regulation and transferable values but
it will be very important for example if
we think about sustainability that we
not only introduce a new digital asset
but that it generates impact so we need
to add meaning to a certain nominal
Factor uh and this will be uh I think
the the most relevant aspect of
tokenization that we create digital
units for whatever underlying asset but
that we can optimize its use we can
incentivize uh certain
behaviors investment in tokenized real
estate represents one of the most recent
advancements in the property industry
tokenization enables houses and
apartments to be divided and sold in
numerous smaller
units small programs act as a bridge
between the property and an online
trading
platform hence tokens created digital
representation of a property
facilitating its digital
transfer is many potential investors are
either unwilling to enter this Market on
a large scale or able to do so due to
factors such as lack of equity or
difficulties in obtaining debt
financing the concept of tokenization
offers a significant Advantage by
enabling the smallest unit of investment
to be acquired at a much lower
threshold for instance a flat owner
could split a property worth 100,000
into 1,000 tokens each token would be
valued at €100 representing a small
portion of the
flat investors would then hold the
rights to a particular percentage of
rental income with each token after
deducting costs like property tax
repairs and insurance investors stand to
profit as the apartment increases in
value over time and rle income
grows another benefit of tokenization is
the ability to convert the individual
tokens anytime 20 47 via apps or trading
platforms furthermore the need to visit
a notary and have the property or share
in it notorized before purchasing is
eliminated purchasers can efficiently
manage their tokens through a mobile
wallet application the app's features
may vary depending on its design
allowing users to track their incoming
payments monitor token value
fluctuations via displays and sell
tokens through their
smartphones real estate tokens follow
similar regulations to Securities and do
not provide physical ownership of the
underlying property essentially a real
estate token functions as a loan that
the provider utilizes for property
financing the loan's interest is covered
by the rental income which poses a risk
of loss the possibility of rent defaults
and in extreme cases the providers in
solvency increases this risk as compared
to investing through a property fund
which is usually Diversified across many
properties in Germany such a scenario
isn't yet to be realized due to the
absence of a regulatory framework that
facilitates securitization of property
rights associated with land and real
estate the process of purchasing a
property is still associated with
significant bureaucracy lengthy
procedure and subsequently high
costs digital art projects were the
first to bring tokenization to public
attention with the assistance of
non-fungible tokens digital art pieces
are typically secured as a whole in the
blockchain in March 2021 American Artist
people sold a digital collage comprising
5,000 individual images for an
extraordinary 69.5 335 million us at an
auction the single tweet by Jack dorsy
founder of Twitter was purchased by a
fan for an impressive sum of $2.9
million us my name is ever fresh also
known as Sebastian FIFA so that's my
real name we are not going to see
anything like we've seen in 2021 so that
that ship has sailed My Hope actually is
that um the market will reach a more
mature state where um um price levels
are reasonable and artists can actually
live off their art sales in that digital
space it's it's never going to be
everyone that's that's clear but you
know like that that's not how it how it
works so it's always just going to be a
few that will be able to make a living
out of it if you look at the sheer
numbers the people collecting crypto is
growing and growing and growing my name
is Sergio Roberto schmal I'm the founder
and CEO of magal mgal stands for meta
Art Gallery there is of course the 2021
January bubble where you had a crypto
Art nft Market explosion with uh 14,000
per. if you have such a high increase
you fall down very very briefly so what
we are doing right now we are trying to
get a new base level and from that level
we can progress together with crypto
together with Bitcoin together with
everything that is behind it our tokens
may be obtained from any location
worldwide allowing for International
Investment in the art industry Twitter
is the main uh uh platform to promote
your your stuff uh in the nft world and
um you can also use other uh social
media platforms but Twitter is by far
the one with the most impact I reach my
audience mainly through Twitter of
course I promote my work on on other
social media platforms as well but I've
not noticed any correlation directly to
sales uh through other platforms than
Twitter I would say the the biggest
Trend right now is the thing that we are
doing coming from the metaverse and
coming into in real life so you can only
feel crypto art if you can touch it if
you can see it like here on our screens
and this is this is the step that a
gallerist needs to do with the
assistance of nonf funable tokens
digital art pieces are typically secured
as a whole in the blockchain despite an
artist creating multiple nfds of an
identical image each NFD possesses a
distinct identity within the
blockchain
on and that means these tokens are
essentially unique we can illustrate
this concept by considering a one coin
when we hold this coin in our hand we do
not distinguish it from any other 1o
coin as they have identical purchasing
power such coins are referred to as
fungible the same principle applies to
Securities such as BMW shares we do not
differentiate between individual shares
as they are fungible the BMW share
represents identical voting rights and
value non-fungible tokens nfts Can Be
likened to artworks such as owning a
unique picoso painting or the Mona Lisa
while forgeries may exist the genuine
Mona Lisa is one of a kind and
non-fungible with no other exact copies
art also employs concept of limited
edition prints where a photo may have
for instance only 100 copies each with a
unique
number these numbered prints belong to a
specific series although numerous tokens
can be used the idea is for each token
to be exclusively identifiable on the
other hand fungible security tokens are
identical and can be exchanged for each
other so you have some uh gray area I
would say Also regarding nfts so we have
Dy nfts are not covers and non pable
tokens however they really it's not
because you call something an nft that
it won't be under MAA so they really are
mentioning that if something is issued
in a large series uh it's an indicator
of Def fungibility so then it doesn't
necessarily mean it will be an nft uh
but again what is the large series we
don't know yet so we hope hope we'll
have some clarification that down the
road but so those little things we can
play with words you don't know
especially that the technology evolve so
quickly most nft sales are actually
auctions they're not auctions in a
classical sense uh where there's you
know like a guy with a hammer but it's
it's just um you usually put your your P
your piece on a platform uh with a with
a reserve and once the reserve is met um
then there's like a um you can Define
that how long the the auction goes but
usually it's like a 24-hour auction and
then the timer starts and it runs for 24
hours and then it depends if other
people put in their bids as well if the
price goes up or not most platforms take
between 5 and
15% some also take 20 most take between
5 and
15% tokenization can be a useful tool
for making art accessible to a large
audience it simplifies the process of
investing in art making it easy safe and
reliable for artists themselves is
tokenization a promising way to sell art
work in theory artists could even offer
themselves as capital Investments to
investors as a result artists can
generate a steady stream of additional
income if their value increases
investors will earn a
profit the market the Art Market remains
considerably unclear necessitating a
thorough knowledge of the players the
influencing factors and the Dynamics of
this Market in order to be competitive
when buying works of
art our collection of works from the top
100 artists is usually unavailable at
local galleries but is sourced from the
leading international galleries without
access artwork becomes either
unobtainable or extremely expensive due
to multiple trade flows each resulting
in price
increases fractional ownership of an
asset in the art industry is
demonstrated through ART security tokens
ests these digital assets correspond to
a portion of an
artwork previously this Market was
exclusive to the super rich due to the
exorbitant prices of art prices are
often in the millions which few can
afford but art trade is changing that we
possess a meticulous network of art
experts who identify appealing works on
your behalf the entire process involves
a complex data analysis procedure we
digitally store all the relevant
information each art work is assigned a
single digital security which comes in
the form of a security token the value
of one token corresponds to one of the
artwork's issue value in essence this is
a fully regulated digital security as
per the new electronic Securities
act this allows us to treat the token
and the security similarly to other
convention
Securities ultimately facilitating their
integration into the financial
industry's
infrastructure thanks to their
assistance anyone can now invest in
works of art that would typically be
excluded from an average Investor's
portfolio under normal
circumstances you can invest in these
works of art indirectly with as little
as €1,000 by purchasing these
tokens this ures that our enthusiasts
with smaller budgets can engage in
magnificent heart
projects even the classic art works are
now available on the blockchain most
recently a blockchain token was created
for Pablo Picasso's renowned Masterpiece
filet oet the responsibility for the
tokenization fell Upon A crypto Bank
situated in Zurich which split the oil
painting into 4,000 individual art
tokens each valued at 1,000 Swiss Franks
these tokens were subsequently
transformed into blockchainbased
Securities that offer a clearcut legal
right to the original and one of a kind
painting dating back to 1964 in
Switzerland it's unle as an investor you
do not acquire a piece of the artwork
itself but rather a securitized claim to
participate in its
performance we made a conscious choice
to avoid fractional ownership and
instead for a security as it aligns with
a traditional investment product and can
seamlessly integrate into the financial
system when works are traded on the
secondary Market often after a prior
purchase the artist store artists
typically do not participate further
however we aim to expand this model in
the long term by exploring the potential
of structuring tokens and smart
contracts currently
this concept remains
uncertain this would allow the artist to
maintain a permanent stake in the value
development of their artwork through a
percentage of
ownership I see a very bright future
when I look at my kids the things they
collect fortnite skins or some digital
weapons for a game this kind of
collection uh feeling is is parallel to
crypto art collection yeah so people
will not hang uh a Picasso in oil
painting on their wall my kids will not
do it they will collect other art and
this may be the art that they are
collecting large art galleries museums
Collections and storage facilities for
works of art May benefit from
tokenization in the near
future these institutions invest
considerable sums in protecting their
works of art against theft and vandalism
which is a costly
undertaking
museums often lack sufficient funding
through entrance fees and other sources
to expand their collections tokenization
has the potential to provide much needed
liquidity it could potentially provide
investors with the opportunity to profit
from The increased value of the art
workor by making the collection or a
portion of it available for
investment a share represents the
security that a company issues depending
on the kind of share it may entitle the
holder to a portion of the profits
dividends or voting rights companies
issue shares in order to raise funds for
their business development however
despite advancements in digitalization
trading in shares remains inefficient in
many areas in the event that you wish to
invest in shares buying an entire share
is typical and acccessory yet shares
from large firms often cost cost more
than
$1,000 this Narrows the poll of
individuals who can accommodate its cost
moreover obtaining ownership and a few
major corporations constrains your
potential for portfolio diversification
through investment in multiple shares my
name is Philip Piper I'm um the founder
of swarm we are a tokenization platform
that does both primary issuance as well
as secondary trading in the past two
years there's been obviously a very high
degree of focus on crypto assets so
basically uh you know Bitcoin and
derivatives of Bitcoin as well as sort
of other native assets that were on sort
of the blockchain like ethereum um but
it's been shown obviously that there's a
very high degree of correlation amongst
all these assets so if the market goes
up everything goes up if the market goes
down and crashes down everything goes
down so in that world there is a need to
actually have something called real
world assets replicated onto chain which
actually derives the value of what they
are from the underlying asset that is
connected with that kind of digital
asset so a good example of that is
basically a stable
coin tokenization enables the purchase
of fractional shares in large
companies rather than obtaining an
entire share partial purchases can be
made to generate a proportional
yield digital Securities can be created
through tokenization referred to as
token derivatives which are secured on
the blockchain and thus embedded in a
more versatile infrastructure
essentially shareholders receive a
conventional share but with Benefits
aligned with
cryptocurrencies the value of the
tokenized share is always equivalent to
the share price of the company that
issued it if the value of the deposited
share doubles then the tokenized shares
value also doubles the price analysis of
tokenized shares is like that of shares
as opposed to
cryptocurrencies so stablecoin is
effectively a a token that represents
maybe a dollar so one token equals $1
you should actually have the ability to
put anything that has value anything
that has some kind of substance onto the
blockchain into these trading
environments into the ability to
fractionalize and mobilize these assets
there's there's a very large realm of
different asset uh quality that you can
gain by putting them as a digital asset
onto chain so if you have one Apple
stock that is represented in one token
well you can buy a scent of the napple
stock if you want to right um that you
cannot do in the traditional markets
tokenization significantly reduces the
barriers to entry into the new financial
markets the majority of all companies
worldwide are presently private
companies there's derivative products
that probably mimic some of that but
it's not the degree of flexibility ility
the second thing is that you actually
have a an immediate settlement so if I
go onto one some kind of exchange some
kind of decentralized exchange some kind
of trading venue and you and I agree on
a
price actually by executing on the
blockchain immediately the transfer of
my ownership to you has been executed
normally in the financial markets that
takes 2 to 3 days to settle from
regulatory perspective you know the
United States is also in a unique
position because of the dollar so you
know the dollar is
um was famously once said that the
dollar is the United States currency but
everyone else's problem um but really I
I I don't fully buy that argument I
think that the dollar is also the United
States's problem now because you have
jurisdictions in other parts of the
world that are essentially creating
regulation for digital US dollars in the
future and none none of this is coming
from the US yet so um you know
regulating stable coins is one of the
lower hanging fruit that they could that
they could tackle in terms of you know
reassert in this position of of dollar
hegemony and this is not a this is not a
position that Europe has to the same
degree I mean you know the US dollar
still makes up somewhere on like I think
60% of of of global reserve the United
States political system is also by
design an invitation to struggle and it
has been since since the Declaration of
Independence so you always have to when
you're looking at the US you always have
to think of this the tokenized shares
serve as a link between conventional
stock exchanges such as zetra or the
Frankfurt Stock Exchange and a
cryptocurrency exchange like binance
token transactions can be processed in
mere minutes contingent on the network
and crypto
exchange if you have the ability to
trade on a
24/7 uh basis without any kind of
stoppage of the market it's a it's a
it's a benefit it actually means real
money for people if you can attach
governance processes to these technical
things it is a benefit because you have
a much more real-time interaction with
the way that the asset down below can
actually transact but even more so if
you actually then have the uh confidence
which means that you have some data that
is that is connected with the token that
points to where it actually goes and
what it represents and the live data
reporting what it actually has in terms
of values then suddenly you're not riant
on a quarterly report but you have a
real-time view on it as smart contracts
perform buy and sell orders of tokens on
a blockchain there's no longer a need to
rely on broker or Banker as an
intermediary so I would say that you
know broadly those would be some of the
um some of the aspects where where
tokenization will will transform the
financial industry whether or not you
buy that there will be a complete
removal of intermediaries it will
certainly you know limit the role of
intermediaries or diminish the frequency
of intermediaries in certain Financial
transactions in the world of
tokenization in the end it all
represents something that has some kind
of resemblance in real life so so
there's a trust element that needs to be
created which also means that if the
token gets lost it really depends on how
you've set it up you can actually sort
of then make sure that it's either you
know respecting who the real owner is so
you know or basically gets redistributed
back to the original owner it's just an
efficiency technology selling company
shares involves lots of people and takes
a while due to
bureaucracy we need to unite the
technical possibilities in the
traditional world the latter insists on
maintaining the status quo as it has
proven stable over the last few decades
there are stakeholders who profit from
this naturally and conversely the Defi
and crypto Community advocates for
self-determination in every aspect
however the reality likely lies
somewhere between these extremes and we
must construct
accordingly investors cannot access
these companies financial institut
itions usually invest in these companies
using costly loans or investment funds
thus the market experiences low levels
of liquidity yes I think it will affect
more the B2B space because for us as end
users we are interested in usability and
of course in trust uh but we're not
necessarily interested if a banking or
fintech app is using technology a or
technology B especially if we talk about
Mass adoption then this should not play
a role uh it should be a well performing
app investors usually make long-term
Investments however if the company
management changes its direction it is
not easy for investors to exit in such
cases they may attempt to influence the
company
management just to think of this as well
it's an open system and therefore
everyone has access that's also not
entirely true it means that depending
how you set up the system and that very
much depends on what asset it represents
you have restrictions that you
artificially have to build into the
system that only a certain type of
customer can buy into those specific
asset tokens uh or that there's only a
certain behavior that is allowed to be
executed with the token so there's a
there's a very much a technology
enforced restriction but what it gives
you is actually a much higher degree of
Confidence from a regulatory process as
well that because it's code and because
it's actually um enforcing what the code
is being told to do that you know you
cannot really bypass it we expect
tokenization and blockchain Technology
to play a role to design more efficient
uh and streamline processes so that's
step number one then we will potentially
tokenize and also use blockchain
technology to finance in different ways
and to tokenize different assets so
that's let's say a growth aspect
depending on regulation but also on
let's say strategic decisions some fully
automated Neo blockchain Banks or Neo
blockchain players are on the market uh
we can expect that new use cases and a
whole new set of process designs um will
see the day of light so this means uh a
totally new category uh targeting new
use cases that are not uh right there
available discussions regarding the
energy industry's future increasingly
center around energy
tokenization renewable energies have
grown inre increasingly popular in our
current ERA wind and solar Parks
continue to attract a growing number of
investors my name is Eko I am CEO of
real Port decentralization of energy is
already there and it's only going to
accelerate I think the past years
considering the Ukraine war and
considering the the the the strive of
governments and our society to become
more independent has shown an incredible
boom of rooftop solar and decentralized
energy um so as not only the companies
and the supply chains grow more mature
it's going to be even easier for for for
tenants of houses and for owners of
houses in order to number one put solar
into the
roof and then it's a matter of
connecting that among the various
decentralized hubs meaning from one roof
to another and into the grid in a smart
way and I do think that technology can
play
fantastic the energy sector's intricate
network is hindered by outdated
infrastructure and numerous inefficient
processes utilizing blockchain can
enhance the efficiency of the energy
Supply and efficiency means saving costs
saving costs means that you can bring in
smaller projects and smaller projects
also means that you can bring in smaller
investors biggest Advantage is for the
smaller guys it's making it more
efficient making making access more
efficient and also enabling smaller wind
farms in order to participate within the
energy
economy thanks to its decentralized
architecture it can document the supply
chains of multiple energy producers
simultaneously which is a much more
complex process with centralized systems
in such systems every producer has to
First send their data to a central
location for bundling and processing in
a decentralized blockchain network
anyone can feed the data
directly by means of tokenization a
digital copy of each physical energy
unit can be stored on a blockchain this
automation of administrative processes
can significantly reduce the cost of
energy you know the way we see there two
different forms one form is sharing the
economic performance out of an energy
project or out of a renewable energy
project that means a generator wants to
set up a wind farm and needs investors
right and will promise essentially the
proceeds of this wind farm to be shared
amongst an investors so now we can
tokenize essentially the future proceeds
of these investment invest of this
project with multiple investors so
that's one part and the much more
difficult part is um how do we certify
renewable energy you know through
National agencies and make it fungible
or tradable in a sense
[Music]
blockchain technology allows for the
tracing of energy from the source to the
end consumer certificates can be issued
if required for proof of purchase this
can be a crucial Factor particularly
considering the stringent regulations
for renewable
energy currently it is difficult to
ascertain whether the energy derives
from wind solar or another source a
third party is required to certify the
origin and these certificates may be
traded green washing is facilitated
there's there's various legislative and
also regulatory aspects around that
number one is the EU taxonomy which
which noways tells us what is green what
is not green so that gives guidance to
investors and also to the issuers of
financial products and number two there
is also a self-disclosure regulation
called sfdr so every publisher every
issuer of financial products will need
to sell assess themselves whether they
are highly sustainable article 9 or not
sustainable basically article 7 and that
will give consumers tremendous guidance
as to what is green what is not green so
that means the leeway to kind of move
around and kind of greenwash has
becoming a whole lot
smaller tokenized certificates can be
produced by the supplier providing an
indisputable origin of the energy
generated these certificates are
securely stored in the blockchain
ensuring that the data cannot be
altered governance
token governance tokens are a particular
type of token that some companies issue
especially those in the technology field
or what are called decentralized
autonomous
organizations these tokens Grant certain
rights to their owners in terms of
technicalities they are often the rc20
tokens following the standard that many
other token types adhere to but the
rights they confirm May differ from
Securities tokens for example voting
rights are frequently represented by
governance tokens which are ued by
companies and owned by those who
purchase them by possessing governance
tokens I am granted the right to vote on
certain matters if a company wishes to
make changes such as implementing
technical modifications token holders
have a say this means that not only do I
get money if I keep this token and
expect to make a profit in the future
but I also have a say in how things are
done and can join communities where my
opinion counts depending on how many
tokens I
have now the Big Challenge here lies how
do consumers be it a business consumer
or even a regular retail consumer buy
into certificated or into certified
renewable energy sources and that's
where blockchain can provide a huge
benefit and the vision is that
eventually you'll be able to match
certificates at the time of production
with consumption at the time when you
really need
it tokenization will increasingly
facilitate investment into wind farms
and other renewable energy sources the
process of investing in a solar Park
using tokens will soon become common
practice the same principle will apply
to the purchasing of electricity from
various energy
sources specifically in the field of
solar energy the initial Supply buyers
have already implemented the
tokenization of their plants there are
also wind power plant platforms that
connect plant operators with companies
and private
individuals tokenization allows token
owners to become co-owners of a wind
turbine and generate proportional
returns by selling the generated
electricity additionally plant operators
benefit from tokenization sin SE
provides another opportunity to directly
collect capital for the plant giving
them off to high liquidity however the
management of energy is still largely
centralized there is considerable
progress to be made before the new
technology is widely
adopted um the next step is now
connecting neighborhoods um the same way
as larger projects of renewable energies
are now participating entire communities
in exchange for the permission of
erecting a solar farm or a wind farm in
into participating into that right in
into into the into the consumption of
the energy which is being produced and
and that will also create communities
which will be able to uh dispatch and to
to trade energy amongst themselves and
amongst multiple communities so yes it's
it it is on the way difficult to say
really right I I think you know Germany
is probably the largest in Europe um uh
rooftop solar Market um in that in that
in that respect has the has the most
installation
but you see this trend everywhere um you
see France has very very strong
regulation and in the UK in Italy as
well as well um I think you can we must
see it as a pan European
move the demand for sustainably and
ethically sourced products has been
increasing in recent years with Society
calling for greater transparency in
Supply
chains tokenizing the supply chain is a
key step in ensuring incredible product
transparency for consumers in line with
growing concerns for sustainability
human rights and Animal
Welfare tokenizing the supply chain is a
key step in ensuring credible product
transparency for consumers the
technology shows potential particularly
in light of a recently enacted supply
chain due diligence act which seeks to
demonstrate that organizations have not
breached their obligations with regards
to Environmental and human rights to
diligence it is crucial for companies to
document accurately every stage of their
supply chain to enable tracking and
proving of sustainability to both
authorities and consumers tokenization
technology has made product tracking
parsible across the value Chain by using
a standard smartphone all relevant
product information can be collected and
stored in a token which can be used
through an app for storage of any type
of information retrieval of any
production step or raw material is
possible at any time with a reliable
system Global Supply chains can be
traced with ease by deploying blockchain
technology for documentation artificial
intelligence can assist in evaluating
risks by scrutinizing supplier contracts
for adherence to Human Rights and
environmental
standards firms can make prompt
modifications to regulatory arrangements
as required
tokenization in agriculture permits
Farmers to convert their produce into
tokens enabling International investors
to invest in Regional agricultural
Commodities the healthc care industry is
using tokenization to manage
confidential data from patients and
Health Care
organizations while the logistics sector
is exploring a comparable concept aiming
to remedy and administrative issue
through the transfer of the bill of
lading onto the
blockchain so that means that we can
expect uh that if tokenization is
becoming part of let's say the
underlying process setup for financial
transactions that the total Market size
will be bigger than today's um financial
asset U Market volume but of course this
will not happen overnight it will happen
in different steps depending on
regulation on Innovation and on enal
acceptance we need Democratic
discussions about things we need
governance so it could take anything
between 5 and 20 years and it will
happen in steps but the addressable
Market size will become
bigger although blockchainbased asset
tokenization has numerous benefits and
is becoming more popular it also has
[Music]
restrictions one disadvantage of tokens
presently is their scalability regarding
the underlying
blockchains
if one were to tokenize all Securities
currently existing in the worldwide
Securities market and place them onto a
blockchain then the blockchains would
fail to accommodate the resultant
transaction
volume this would cause the system to
become overloaded and overwhelm The
crucial drawback of tokens they do not
adhere to a technical standard but
rather operate on the underlying
platforms specifically the blockchains
where these tokens exist tokens exist
there is a risk of cyber criminals
accessing and stealing digital
assets although blockchain technology is
believed to be highly secure successful
attacks on cryptocurrency exchanges and
other blockchainbased systems have
occurred typically attackers obtained
access not through the blockchain but
through their connection points
therefore it is crucial to develop a
comprehensive Ive independable cyber
security
system I think MAA is a great first step
so you know if you can think of like a
global regulatory waterfall that
trickles down you know I would say that
Europe is kind of sitting at at the top
at the crest of this waterfall and I
think that a lot of what we've achieved
with MAA um as as as a continent is now
making its way into the regulatory
thinking and rationale and other
jurisdictions thank banks have
traditionally acted as asset
managers they aim to broaden their range
of services and provide customers with
the most extensive parsible
Choice as a result they have begun to
investigate the tokenization of
assets it's possible that in the future
Banks May oversee the issuance and
trading of tokenized
assets fintech has become one of the
fastest growing Industries in recent
times
one area currently undergoing
significant innovation in tokens is
Payment Processing security tokens
provide a relevant
example bonds for instance offer their
holders regular coupons which may
consist of an interest rate paid
annually the token can be loaded with
vast quantities of information enabling
it to determine the amount of the
interest coupon collect the
corresponding sum from the assurer and
then distribute it automatically to the
investors in the conventional banking
industry a paying agent is assigned when
a company releases a bond the paying
agent typically a bank ensures that the
assur makes timely interest payments and
distributes them to investors this
process can be automated using program
code such as smart contracts with the
added benefit of transferring this
information to the
Token talking about the ecological
impact of blockchains I think is a big
deal but we as an industry have to ask
ourselves what's right and wrong right A
lot of people from looking at it from
the outside then think that that all
that energy is the same Energy Mix as
the energy that goes into our daily
consumption and as much as that was the
case it's changed dramatically so
there's a lot of um regenerative
energies that have have been started to
be used the hydro energy wind energy but
also solar energy that basically go into
these uh node computations and this is
energy that never has been used in a
consumer's perspective so it's not
competing against the energy that you
and I use in our daily lives more than
60% right now is already regenerative
energy that the Bitcoin Network actually
uses and the rest is still something to
work
on financing through tokens has the
potential to significantly transform the
global economy in the future companies
can digitally map tangible assets and
fund them through decentral ized means
decentralized Solutions will supersede
traditional Financial
Services uh and I think that in the
future what we're likely going to see is
on the on the side of payments and
crypto and you know we'll have different
digital currency areas so you could have
stable coins and uh Commercial Bank
money tokens and different kinds of
cbdcs and these will all exist in some
and cash will all exist in some in some
you know as German say Mom r some mix
together uh and I don't think that one
will necessarily crowd out the other on
the other hand I I also believe that a
lot of why we see an interest in crypto
and I think globally it's about like 23%
of of of people globally hold crypto in
Europe I think the average is around 17
so we're still on the Lower Side
compared to the global average but it's
growing and I think it's it's confidence
right so like if people don't have
confidence in the system they they look
for Alternatives and I think that the
Challenge from a political perspective
for the for the for the for the
governments for the nation states is how
do we instill confidence in our systems
in an age of digital transformation and
there's no easy answer to that question
um and I think that at the same time it
might be a little naive to assume that
crypto can solve all of the world's
problems so I would say that um we need
a a some sort of tempered optimism right
or or tailored
optimism there is still a lack of
standardization of networks requiring
the development of legal standards to
provide clarity and security for
companies and
investors the impact of this can already
be seen in our society with a technology
already
[Music]
prevalent